and one that Blake wheeler had marked on his
calendar the moment he signed with the New York
Rangers organization this one is officially
underway between the Rangers and the Jets the
first of two meetings here's a quick shot on net
from who else but Blake wheeler and stopped by
Conor helot tro heading to the middle everybody
looking to shoot nobody can get a shot away and
instant picked up by Schmid Thro tip in front huk
had to be careful will gy was lurking as well 12
minutes a game but in this game out there more
often for Peter laviolet he's using Blake wheeler
and they've had some chances there's the tip in
Rangers come up with it DeAndre Miller scored
the OT game winning goal against Vancouver on
Saturday for his first of the Season here's a
shot on net that eluk was standing in the way up
Fox up ahead to he Quick Pass tamy paner Aaron
red hot to start the season tried to cut to the
middle but he was cut off by Lowry and now Mason
Appleton has an open Lane of the Zone he comes in
with speed Appleton dishes shooting was Peretti
and a blocker save from shurin Dylan launches one
to the net and it's stopped by shesterkin it's in
his glove appon playing the body on Schneider
need Rider here's the Jets third line looking
for some offense like they have this season near
Rider comes to the front the shot blocked Mory
shoots into traffic and Ricochet is away Face Off
to the left of shurin up was laying there now laer
has it delivers it to guson and heel trying to
move out with it unable to do so guson takes a
look back to heel back to Guston La prier off the
boards over to heel a chip and Chase El falls in
the corner still gets it to panan trouba takes
it from Miller and there's a goal from paner
as he tips it home and the Rangers are up one to
nothing with a late goal in the first period And
yet paner gets inside position and defensively
you're not going to like that here's shley knows
he's got that and yet he's late getting there
and Panera just perfect pass he's on the back
hand tis it in and you see Shipley's reaction
he knows that he was just half a step late in
reacting watch by too chance for Peretti and
he grabs a hold of that puck brings it into
the Rangers Zone Peretti pass over a shot
and [Applause] austinson [Applause] [Music]
David Guston answers back for the Chets it's
tied at one here he right in the middle hang
on hang on hang on and both defenseman come
to him and that opens up gustus and gives him
just enough room and a Rolling Puck and the
reason gusers can get it up so quickly the
Puck's rolling it's in front of him he just
Scoops it to the net and it beats your sterk
and short side all tamy paner and the breadman
celebrating his birthday today turned 32 years
old rajil be was about the same size as paner
gets it back to the point Fox to the bage at
back to Fox paner takes a look wait shoots
hell may have gotten a piece of that here's
Fox reverses theage at surveys Fox from up top
moving to the middle switching spots Arin right
arm stopped from Hell about steering that aside
paner this pass troch had some trouble with it
allowing the Jets to clear the [Applause] Zone
troch stick handling through rather smooth there
at the Blue Line zage at all the way across pass
to the middle tro and Sh and it's at the goal line
but didn't it cross no reversing Dello to Mory
shot pass there over to AO could get it on net
ifal working it back to Peretti Mory across to
Dello ahead for naskov he dishes Kyle Connor's
out there now all the way over to Mory he shoots
and shurin in position to answer that and he has
to reach for it you see Igor sherin's got time
he's got a reach back his hands are too far
apart he's leading the Jets in his shots and
shot attempts he's directed eight towards
the net he's only got three M shley has no
shots none block and none attempts kept it
in momentarily and now a potential two
onone yes Here Comes Peretti with eers
a passing front to Peretti couldn't put it
home eer still has it WRA around to he scored
Point number 400 for Nikolai eers the go
ahead goal for the Jets in the third pass
Peretti shoots it right through there's eers
hardcap keeps the life going beautiful pass
and Peretti shot it right through now Nikolai
eers right through shurin bring it out and give
himself an angle he doesn't try and just tuck it
doesn't just go post he brings it all the way out
so that he's got some room fiveable rder over
to tro paner Waits this is Fox what timer and
it's in the net this game is tied the New York
Rangers Power Play prowess continues and it's
Chris krider who tips that one home Chris cder
great hand ey standing in front of Conor El and
get the shot through that's all they're trying
to do they get the shot through little rer and
krider gets his stick on it gets it by Conor hel
you see Fox just lets it Go fan get to play four
lines 534 to go here in the third period Rangers
and jets a quick shot blocked again this time by
Bonino unable to clear the pucko as Kyle Conor
sends it deep cley moving around kept in at the
line Mor C over to Dello he pushes it ahead I
fell front shurin a fabulous save eor shurin
and we on display has no idea where this is but
he can feel it just squeak through so he rolls
around and so with just over 18 seconds
left in the third period the Jets on the
man advantage looking for the winner
as Kyle Conor skates to the puck but
the Rangers clear Winnipeg 0 for two this
power plate looks like it might lead into
the overtime that seems inevitable and
yes we are headed to overtime with the
Jets we're set to go here Rogers Monday night
hockey Rangers Jets sudden death over time as
the Rangers have possession stripped him
of the pocket Pon reverses shy Le trying
to Pilot through the pass over to Kyle Connor
moving towards the net Pon got his stick on
that puck but couldn't get it on net last
minute a play here in overtime tro crosses
the Blue Line a pass in front to lapr they
couldn't connect to his Fox who had sent it
towards himon stick was midair still has
it though is kandre Miller overtime here
on Saturday for the Rangers he's out there now
paner moving driving one timer from the and he
scores Mika zaban at has scored
in two straight and that's the
overtime winner the Rangers have won five straight